one of our Kelly's live-in girlfriends
is now denying that she called him a
monster online in a new video Joycelyn
savage says she did not write the post
to the crowdfunding site patreon
describing Kelly as controlling and
abusive she says whoever did write them
is an impostor
now those posts have since been removed
our national correspondent Jericka
Duncan is here I'm listening with both
ears because this story seems to take on
so many twists and turns yeah what is
jocelyn sang Joycelyn sang now she had a
lot to say I mean essentially she said
that that was not her in the video
obtained by TMZ Savage says she claims
that the singer abused her are quote
nonsense she also said she will not be
part of the assassination of Kelly's
name career and character that's not me
I'm not even that kind of girl that
would do something like that and betray
him Joycelyn savage is fiercely denying
new claims of abuse by our Kelly nearly
two weeks ago on the website patreon
someone claiming to be Savage says Kelly
abused her and kept her locked up like
an animal the posts allege she was told
what to say in previous videos where she
defended Kelly saying a member of Kelly
staff starved her for days at a time
until she learned her scripted lines
word for word but now Joycelyn says that
was an impostor it's just really really
really sad that somebody would pretend
to be me pretend to be me and put it out
in the world and say they're I'm a
victim that I am brainwashed okay I'm a
sex slave what is your relationship both
of you with with our Kelly in March
Savage and Kelly's other live-in
girlfriend Ezreal Clary told Gayle King
they are happy
he's our full support and we his full
support and all we need is each other
but savages family says they've begged
her for several years to leave Kelly her
mother described phone conversations
with her daughter to Gail I call them
Prison calls because I can tell that
someone is listen to the cause and she
called with the script the savage family
says they are disappointed to learn that
Joycelyn says she was not the person
operating the patreon account in a new
statement they say for nearly
years Joycelyn Savage has not been able
to speak outside of a controlled
environment created by mr. Kelly her
video today was not any different that's
stupid
Kelly is now in jail awaiting trial
facing federal and state sex crime
charges in a March interview with Gale
he strongly denied the allegations
against him how stupid would it be for
me to with my crazy pass and what I've
been through
oh right now I just think I need to be a
monster and hold girls against they will
chain them up in my basement and and
don't let them eat and don't let him out
stop it y'all quit playing quit playing
stuff Kelly's lawyer said in a statement
now that we know that Joycelyn savage
was not the person behind the stories we
know that the stories that she told were
complete fabrications or at least the
person was completely fabricating these
stories Kelly has not said that he's
guilty of these things he's pleaded not
guilty to all charges and is expected to
go to trial in the spring he sees that
he's innocent but I have the same
question how many days 12 days 12 days
between the time that I be on post came
out and what we heard she just said the
video at all no and what's patreon
saying and they apparently paid somebody
well they pulled with this night down
you know this is a crowdfunding site and
the idea was I'm gonna tell you my whole
story if you subscribe and pay this
money
mm-hm well there weren't a lot of people
paying a lot of money to hear what this
person allegedly had to say it's
interesting when I did the interview
with them I didn't know our Kelly was in
the room because he was it was a big
suite and he was around the corner yeah
but the minute they started talking he
started coughing loudly and I know they
heard him I know they heard them whether
that affected their answers or not I
still don't know but they were very
emphatic about know they're there on
their own free will and if they wanted
to leave they could